você está
certo olá a todos eu gostaria de dar
esta palestra em memória do dr.  Tony Witten,
que foi muito tristemente morto na semana passada
em um acidente de bicicleta e ele foi um
dos melhores pensadores em
conservação da vida selvagem em seu trabalho no Banco Mundial
e, em seguida, lugares como caídos por nenhum
internacional porque ele desenvolveu idéias
estão desenvolvendo pequenos negócios nas
comunidades  para ajudá-los a proteger sua
vida selvagem, ele procurou incorporar
ideias em sistemas de crenças e, o mais
importante, falou sobre
envolver os jovens na
conservação da vida selvagem e é sobre isso que essa conversa
é e se ele estivesse aqui hoje,
diria a você que estamos vivendo
o maior evento de extinção na
história da Terra esta é a sexta
extinção e provavelmente a maior
de todas e desta vez causada por uma
única espécie a humanidade e os jovens
intrinsecamente obtêm isso com mais frequência do
que a geração de seus pais e eles
querem ajudar e isso é  sobre o que é este
projeto Vou
falar sobre uma organização chamada
Operação Wallacea, que é  nomeado em homenagem a
Alfred Russel Wallace, um contemporâneo de
Darwin e co-criador da
teoria da evolução pela seleção natural,
mas também o pai da biogeografia,
porque passou a vida viajando
pelo mundo para locais remotos
como a Amazônia e o Extremo Oriente e
olhando para  a distribuição de espécies
e há uma área do mundo que se
chama região de Wallacea que leva o
nome dele e foi onde essa
organização começou a trabalhar e o que
eles fazem é financiar acadêmicos e nós financiamos
200 acadêmicos e 75 estudantes de doutorado e
esse financiamento vem das mensalidades  taxas
que são pagas por estudantes 3.000 deles
todos os anos que então vão para esses
locais remotos do mundo e ajudam esses
cientistas agora é ciência real essa é
a primeira pergunta bem
fácil de responder porque se não está sendo
publicado não é ciência  e estamos
trabalhando apenas do início de junho
ao início de agosto de cada ano
e até agora publicamos 33  0
artigos agora não do que os quatro em
periódicos revisados por pares, incluindo alguns de alto
mpacto como
natureza, por isso está trabalhando a partir de uma ciên
ia, nosso ponto de vista do que faz esse
étodo de financiamento permite desen
olver conjuntos de dados de longo prazo, porque se você
solicitar uma bolsa  você receberá uma bolsa
por três anos, é isso no final,
você tem que parar,
enquanto para a ecologia você não precisa de três
anos de dados, você precisa de cinco 10 15
20 anos e é isso que esse
método de financiamento permite  para fazer agora
não adianta apenas fazer pesquisas para
publicar artigos e traçar a perda de
biodiversidade, então a ideia por trás
disso é estruturar os dados para
que fiquem em um formato que possa ser usado para
intervenção de conservação se necessário
e se for necessário então  os
cientistas continuam monitorando para ver se
essas intervenções realmente funcionam ou
não, então é baseado em ciência real, então a
questão é se os alunos realmente podem ajudar
nesse tipo de trabalho?
coisas como
a ciência cidadã que é onde você treina as
pessoas em uma técnica e então você
vai para a floresta com supervisão, por
exemplo, e eles coletam dados e
esses dados são usados diretamente em publi
ações ou planos de manejo, bem, há u
a gama limitada de coisas que você
pode fazer os alunos fazerem isso pela primeira
vez nos trópicos, mas há alguns
deles, felizmente, são algumas das partes mais
importantes que temos que fazer, por
exemplo, em uma chuva tropical, pois é uma
das informações mais importantes que
você precisa  sabemos quanto
carbono está lá porque cerca de 20
% das emissões mundiais de gases de efeito
estufa são provenientes do desmatamento
nos países em desenvolvimento e, portanto, as
nações ricas estão financiando
departamentos florestais nos países em desenvolvimento para
fazê-los parar de desmatar e a
quantidade de carbono que economizam  é então
contado para seus orçamentos nacionais de carbono
e este é um grande negócio, então,
por exemplo, os noruegueses deram
ao Indonesi  ans 1 bilhão de
dólares para ser usado para créditos de carbono, então,
quando você entra em uma floresta, uma
das primeiras informações que você
precisa saber é o carbono que está lá e,
para isso, você precisa de dados de satélite para observar
a distribuição de  floresta e
tipos de floresta e então você precisa de muitos alunos
para ir na floresta e medir as árvores em
parcelas padrão e você precisa de duas
medidas, isso é tudo que você precisa para saber
o diâmetro à altura do peito da
árvore, o que significa colocar uma fita métrica em
volta dela e  você precisa estimar a
altura das árvores usando um clinômetro
agora sabemos que os alunos podem fazer isso com
precisão porque testamos e
comparamos com silvicultores profissionais
e os resultados não são significativamente
diferentes
vamos mudar para a África agora você está no
meio  de uma reserva que tem
cerca de três metros de cercas de animais dentro de pessoas de
fora que tem sido uma estratégia muito bem sucedida
na África do Sul tanto que
em muitos casos o número de animais
nessas res  erves cresceu a tal
ponto que agora estão contra a
capacidade de carga, então quando você for lá,
a primeira coisa que o gerente vai
perguntar é: você pode me dizer qual é a
capacidade de carga dessa reserva e
para isso você precisa  para saber dois bits de
informação primeiro o que está lá agora
e para isso você precisa de estudantes e
muitos veículos e você dirige pela
reserva e toda vez que você vê um
mamífero você para e então você toma a
distância perpendicular da trilha até
o animal o que  espécie é a
condição de macho fêmea e depois continua e
o que estás a fazer é este
processo chamado amostragem à distância por isso se
estás a trabalhar com elefantes digamos
que tens um elefante parado no teu
rasto terás de ser grosseiramente
incompetente para não  veja, você tem
cem por cento de chance, mas à medida que o
animal se afasta, essa probabilidade
de observação diminuirá e a
forma dessa curva depende do
habitat porque você pode ver elefantes a
muito mais facilmente na savana do que na floresta
e em parte pelo tipo de espécie
é ótimo eu cortei é muito mais difícil de ver
por exemplo então você faz essas curvas
para todas as espécies e todos os habitats e
tudo é feito automaticamente por computador
e você pode  então calcule exatamente o
que tem lá agora sabemos de
quanta comida eles precisam porque isso é
publicado para todas as espécies e se estivermos
lá no meio do inverno
digamos que temos dois meses antes de
começar a crescer novamente então  podemos calcular
exatamente quanta forragem é necessária,
então tudo que você precisa saber é o que resta
na reserva e para isso você precisa de uma
fila de alunos andando pela
reserva pegando cada folha de até dois
metros de altura e depois olhando para o
valor calórico e peso total,
obviamente, você tem que ter guardas armados
e treinamento e assim por diante para fazer
isso, mas fornece uma maneira muito precisa
de descobrir exatamente qual é a
capacidade de carga, mas há muito  das coisas que os
alunos não podem fazer você não pode mandá-los
para uma centésima floresta nublada e pedir-
lhes para contar pássaros porque há
tantas espécies que eles não poderiam fazer
isso e para isso você tem um líder um
especialista que está realmente levando o  dados,
mas o que os alunos estão fazendo é que
eles estão ajudando a acelerar isso, então se
você fizer uma contagem de pontos, o que você realmente
faz é gravar todas as
espécies que você ouve ou vê nos próximos
dez minutos para que alguém esteja descrevendo
o  ao anotar os tempos de
cada espécie alguém está usando
telêmetros para estimar as distâncias e
alguém está olhando ao redor dos 360
graus para ajudar a
acelerar todo o processo e esse é
o caso em muitos tipos de pesquisas, mas
não  empolgados estamos pensando
que os próprios cientistas são
infalíveis porque não são e este
é um bom exemplo há uma técnica
onde você procura répteis e
anfíbios com autoridade caminha pela
floresta e seu mar  rch em ambos os lados de um
transecto e então testamos a
eficiência disso escondendo sapos de plástico e
cobras de plástico em uma floresta e então
enviamos estudantes e depois acadêmicos
e guias locais para verificar o quão
eficientes eles eram e os mais
eficientes por um longo tempo  como eram os
guias locais porque eles estão muito mais acostumados a
ver diferentes tons de verde em uma
floresta então sempre que possível tentamos
usar novas tecnologias para que possamos ter
uma verificação independente dos conjuntos de dados
bem vamos supor que você queira contar peixes
em um  recife então você quer saber quantos
peixes em um recife em particular você
vai usar uma técnica chamada
levantamento de sensores visuais subaquáticos então você vai
mergulhar com sua fita métrica você
vai colocá-la ao longo digamos os 10 metros
contorno e você vai parar por
cinco minutos porque você assustou o
peixe e agora vamos nadar de
volta um metro e meio acima da fita
e você vai contar tudo
abaixo de você e uma carne e  da metade de cada
lado em um cubo daqui para frente então vou
reproduzir um pouco de vídeo espero
que você faça isso por favor gostaria que você
contasse todos os peixes que você vê eu preciso de um
nome para cada peixe don  não perca nenhum, eles
têm que vir naquela caixa e você tem que
obter o comprimento de todas as espécies e
isso é apenas um pequeno filme de
Moçambique alguns dos recifes são muito
mais complexos do que isso
usando vídeo estéreo nadando ao longo dele está
gravando os peixes  e toda a análise
é então feita de volta no laboratório os
alunos colocam os nomes dos peixes
abaixo das fotos e se
errarem a gente sabe porque temos uma imagem
e o software calcula a distância
das câmeras até o peixe então se  ele
não vem em sua caixa mágica você não
conta se ele clicar na frente
e atrás em uma tela e fizer o mesmo
em sua imagem espelhada e lhe der os
comprimentos para mais ou menos 5% agora isso é
importante  porque o melhor que você pode fazer
debaixo d'água é mais ou menos 50% e o que
você  você pega cada um dos comprimentos
e os cubos de forma a obter o peso
dos peixes por isso estaéuma técnica muito mais precisa
outra nos
recifeséuma medida padrãoéquanto núcleo de coral
existe num recife por isso você mergulha agora  com
sua fita métrica novamente e desta vez
você vai nadar de volta ao longo da fita
e toda vez que ela muda de um
coral duro para uma chamada suave para uma esponja etc
então você vai anotar a
distância e você fará  que 20 30
vezes volte para mim e diga ok, a
resposta é 30%
mais ou menos 10%, mas no próximo ano ela
caiu para 25% e você não pode detectá-la
porque sua amostragem não é poderosa o
suficiente, então o que essa técnica faz  é
você nadar para frente e para trás com uma
GoPro e ela produz uma imagem 3d no seu
computador este é um equipamento de mergulho que colocamos
em um fundo de areia e depois medimos
a precisão em todas as três dimensões
e é fantasticamente preciso, então isso
significa que você pode pegar o recife  fora da
água e colocá-lo em seu computador  er e
então ao invés de estimar a cobertura de corais
você pode medi-la diretamente agora se
você estiver na floresta tropical se
você tiver as florestas da Guiana por
exemplo você tem mil
espécies de pássaros lá você tem que saber os cantos
de cada pássaro  espécies e as
chamadas de contato e as chamadas de vôo até que você
precise de um nível muito alto de especialização, então a
melhor maneira é colocar microfones
na floresta e gravar as chamadas e, uma vez que
você tenha feito isso, podemos olhar os
gritos e ver como é muito comum  ave
nos Neotrópicos você pode então ou você pode
treinar o software para identificar as
espécies-chave, então para que estamos fazendo tudo isso
primeiro para encontrar novas espécies para a
ciência e encontramos muitas dezenas de novas
espécies para a ciência, incluindo as novas
espécies de társios  que foi encontrado em uma
das florestas da Indonésia e
eu sou oito primatas não descobertos e neste
último verão fotografamos esta
borboleta rabo de andorinha e em uma
província remota no norte de Fiji e nenhum
dos especialistas pode identificar  entificá-lo
parece ser uma espécie nova para a ciência e se for
é a primeira nova espécie de
rabo de andorinha nos últimos 50 anos
isso é o déficit de Lineu falta de
informação sobre as espécies mas também precisamos de
informações sobre onde as espécies existentes
estão ao redor do mundo  e há
muita falta de informação que também isso
é chamado de Wallace E e déficit
e é importante porque quando você classifica
o valor de conservação das espécies você faz
isso com base em grande parte em
seus alcances e em muitos casos isso é
baseado no  suposições agora em alguns casos
podemos entrar e encontrar espécies e um
alcance muito maior do que eles pensavam que em
outros casos nós os encontramos em um alcance muito menor
do que costumavam ser então a
questão era se os alunos realmente podem ajudar na
ciência no campo  como isso e
acho que a resposta é sim, há
algumas coisas que eles podem medir diretamente
e usamos esses dados, há muitas
coisas que eles podem ajudar os cientistas a
acelerar todo esse processo e  d é
claro que eles também podem se envolver com as
novas tecnologias, mas enviar
estudantes para lá não apenas obtém dados,
mas muda as pessoas se você colocar alguém em
uma rede no meio da
floresta tropical da Guiana cercada por onças e
pumas por dois meses  ou fazê-los mergulhar
em um recife remoto eles voltam mudando as
pessoas e voltam infundidos para
proteger a vida selvagem e seus
embaixadores da vida selvagem e é em grande medida
o que estamos tentando criar a próxima
geração de embaixadores da vida selvagem obrigado
[Aplausos]
[  Música]